salut et bienvenue dans cette vidéo du
10 septembre et ont saisi pour le 10
septembre on va recommencer avec des
casse tête et on va taper fort c'est
pour ça mais jugées pas sûres les
blagues
aujourd'hui j'avais une idée et on va la
faire cette idée aussi on va se faire du
casse-tête anagama si vous connaissez
pas c'est ses gammes de castets l'a
souvent en métal à difficultés
croissantes dont il ya un code couleur
les jaunes c'est le plus facile 1 2 3
c'est ça c'est 1,3 nancéen 4 on est déjà
aux quatre avec lui là on est à cinq sur
cinq et là on est à 6 sur cinq
impossible impossible n'est pas anaya
m'a alors on va pas se mentir c'est le
genre de casse tête que je déteste
j'aime pas ça donc je me suis dit que
j'allais faire c'est logique le temps
pascal ory c'est tout à fait quand on
déteste un truc
ouais tu tombes way
pour le cheval
on va en faire quand même pour plusieurs
raisons déjà parce que c'est
incontournable et anagama on en voit
partout vraiment il existe fort en a qui
les collectionne là je les ai chopé chez
d'insolubles casse-tête acheté en france
c'est toujours mieux on a une heure
aujourd'hui c'est sa loïc 1 je vais
essayer d'en faire un maximum en une
heure en partant du plus ça en allant
vers le plus fort il est fort probable
que je n'y arrive pas forcément à tout
résoudre simon reste un jeu n'aurait pas
fait potentiellement celui ci j'offre
une vidéo dessus à la demande générale
bien sûr loïc générique des casse-tête
qui sont content ce soir
moi je suis content je vis
on commence avec le cast harmonie
difficulté 2 sur 6 on est deux fois le
médecin des fois ils maîtriseront
difficultés de deux essais marqués ici
il faut le désassembler et le ré
assembler c'est comme ça que ça marche
et anagama c'est toujours le même
principe faute désassembler pour ré
assembler un truc et c'est ça que je
n'ai pas trop moi personnellement dans
les caisses être mais c'est ok on va le
faire donc on a sept notes de musique
que vous voyez avec une enfin on a une
clé de sol avec eux avec une note qui va
falloir du coup il va falloir sortir des
petites alors étudiant ça étudiants ont
correctement en gros c'est le moyen de
sortir c'est quoi c'est de le sortir par
là un parent bas donc il faut que
j'arrive à le passer là dedans et donc
il va falloir que je le tourne autour de
ça j'imagine mais ça c'est trop pt alors
donc déjà si je le passe comme ça
ça me fait descendre d'un cran wise et
ça il va falloir chercher comment
comment on peut le descendre de à chaque
fois d'un cran plus peut-être ça marche
pas comme ça même si je le retourne et
attend 6 6 le bloc là comme ça ça passe
ou pas des castes et on a le droit de
forcer un peu faux pas abîmer évidemment
mais pas hésité à forcer un petit peu
voilà c'est passé voilà je suis pas mal
là aux basses et il sera rondement mené
celui ci je pense non pas encore
parce que là je suis quand même très
très très très pas mal
pas très très très français ce que je
dis si je pouvais le l'inversé la nuit
abc et bien voilà des assemblages ok
maintenant réassemblage et le problème
des réassemblage c'est que des fois tu
sais plus trop comment tu l'as assemblée
donc au début il était là après les
il était là parce que j'arrivais pas à
admettre comme ça non il était comme ça
encore il était comme ça après je
l'avais fait en tournant ici je crois
que l'airé assemblage d anna ya là ils
sont des fois plus relou que la semble
que le nom le réassemblage et plus relou
le désassemblage oui si c'était comme ça
ok là j'étais là je l'avais passé à
l'envers
du coup je les
passais comme ça
et là il était comme ça au début ou
comme ça déjà c'est pas et voilà c'est
bon c'est un assemblage bon ok
difficulté 2 sur 6 il nous a pas fallu
plus de quelques minutes on va passer au
suivant
[Musique]
le suivant c'est le cast gg difficulté 3
sur 6 et effectivement ce sont bien deux
gg qu'on a ici sous nos yeux le gg que
vous allez laisser dans les commentaires
peut-être peut-être on ne sait pas au
fait là on est le 10 septembre au moment
où vous regardez la vidéo c'est quand
même cool autant vous le dire c'est le
jour où je viens de reprendre mes
spectacles après un an et demi d'arrêt
je retourne sur scène avec mon spectacle
d'humour et de mentalisme singularité
dont vous voyez peut-être la fiche si le
hezbollah mais je vous la met je vais
vous la m parlons peu parlons bien les
villes où je repasse ces sont les bijoux
soit je ne suis jamais passé sur je suis
pas passé plus d'une fois mais les
vivres je suis déjà passé 2 3 fois comme
marseille toulouse mulhouse nice les
jeux ne repasse pas dans celui là par
contre je repasse avec vous je suis pas
beaucoup passé bordeaux nantes lille
lyon
dans le 44 j'en fais pas mal dans le 79
du côté tour du côté de toulouse aussi
je reviens et puis la grande dernière
singularité au zénith de paris la
rochelle aussi je serai chez moi à la
rochelle vous avez le lien dans la
description est ce que on se voit à la
fin des spectacles oui est ce que les
anciens billets restent valables
évidemment est-ce que je viens pas trop
loin de chez vous regardez sur le site
internet voilà les gg il va falloir les
désolidariser
donc sur les sorties qu'il ya comme ça
il est à oui bah oui on peut faire ce
genre de mouvement ok peut-être mon but
ce serait que ça et ça soit connecté un
peu comme ça mais pas comme ça
si c'est pas clair dit pas clair dans
les commentaires
donc je pense qu'il faut il faut en
garder un fixe le doré ou argenté peu
importe il faut en garder un fixe et
bouger l'autre au tour sinon une pomme
c'est quoi la position de départ c'est
elle que je retienne pourquoi je devrais
l'air offert à la fin ça y est en photo
ça ouais non la position de départ ça
fait 1 6 et 1 9 comme ça important
qu'est ce qu'il faut les refaire ses
casquettes je vais faire par élimination
quand je suis en hauteur fut bloqué
quand je suis là je suis bloqué quand je
suis là je suis bloqué dans tous les
sens si je me réussit au milieu là je
peux pas le tour n'est pas ce que ça
coince là non plus on ne peut faire ça
une fois que je suis comme ça je peux
pas faire grand chose non plus là non
plus loin non plus là non plus on peut
aller line pitch clash ou bloquer aussi
donc je bloquais de tous les côtés donc
c'est à dire qu'il ya un truc que j'ai
pas compris
la france et moi un truc que j'ai mal
fait le patron doit pas être bloquée de
partout en même temps du coup si là je
peux rien faire
[Musique]
comme ça je déteste c'est vraiment pas
un
c'est quoi cette affaire j'ai concept
intéressant de voir c'était ça
c'était bien ça ou pas ça m'a changé un
peu quelque chose
[Musique]
huit ans c'est pour ça que ces cds
casquette rouge moussa je viens de faire
un truc je sais pas ce que j'ai fait je
ne peux même pas le défaire et leur
comprendre je cherchais la possibilité
un besoin un bien rare et c'est bien
faites ce que je dis mais pas ce que je
fais j'ai dit ce qui serait bien c'est
de garder un des deux fixes pour
toujours se rappeler ce don fait et moi
je suis là alors oui bonjour madame
alors maintenant je cherche juste à
revenir en position initiale des gens
parler comment j'étais bouger toi là à
l'équipe qui allait le fab où on trouve
on arrêtait montre où on a plusieurs
casquettes à faire le temps passe on est
à 3 sur 6 et je galère déjà et ouais
c'est pas mon type de castets lie un
petit coin ici est un petit coin tu es
plus dur en fait il ya des angles un peu
partout en fait qui t'empêche des
rotations voilà bah moi je trouve ça
très joli je pense qu'on pourrait sacrer
à
attend est parvenu en position de départ
s'est retrouvé le défaire de les défaire
sans avoir compris une seule seconde que
je rêvais
[Musique]
oa temps je suis revenu au point de
départ la rb5 va je vais essayer de me
concentrer de bouger que lee et cette
malle à cette main là elle restera figé
pour l'éternité comme ça je comprendrais
les mouvements que j'ai fait à tout
moment je pourrais revenir en arrière ça
va lolo je suis au deuxième le premier
il a pris deux minutes et celui-là je
les estime à 2 heures tu vois là celui
ci l'impasse bankers animaux
je n'ai pas avancé il faut savoir qu'à
un moment donné j'ai fait n'importe quoi
j'ai réussi à revenir lâcher toujours
pas qu'on attend ça c'est pas mal donc à
tan tan tan tan donc en fait là j'ai
fait ça ici c'est tourner notre mère ça
m'avance faire c'est de réfléchir avec
les petits coups d'aile à vouvoyer mal
mais qui empêche les rotations il y en a
une là il y en a un autre là un autre là
un autre là là là et là et ça m'empêche
de tourner comme je veux les choses
c'est pas mal parce que si je fais ça
[Musique]
je suis content je suis content ça
c'était ma faute
enfin c'était comment mais si
c'était ça
[Musique]
j'attends
tenait avant
j'étais là j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait ça j'ai fait ça donnait 69 de
départ là je suis revenu comme au départ
ok 4 state casse tête je classe est
rondement menée cast est sûre
il passe à hexagone hexagone difficulté
4 sur 6 voilà la position de départ
voici la position d'arrivée assemblée
des assemblées robin c'est parti en fait
ce sont des pièces de métal qui sont
creusés à certains endroits là où il
yal'arrivée évidemment c'est qu'on ne
peut pas passer et ça va nous permettre
de les tirer comme ça
on dirait un petit un petit renard c'est
très très mignon ça ça va être gay n'est
en fait là vous voyez la forme de
celui-là il faudrait que j'arrive en
fait à libérer un espace
assez grand pour le faire passer oui oui
c'est joli ça donc lui c'est bon lui ça
passe
lui dans ce sens là
pour apaiser les manquements crédits
s'ils faisaient que ce soit ville pour
sa part voilà ça peut se passer
ah bah oui bah oui mais si c'est passé
comme ça et après comme ça d'accord au
boss est possible lorsque tu imagines
que si lui est passé lui
oui bon c'était pas le défaire plus dur
c'est peut-être le refaire
lui je les passais en dernier donc je
refais tout l inverse du coin lui je les
bras c'est comme ça
[Musique]
et lui du coup il y avait la place comme
ça du coup lui il était là la position
de départ c'est
lui avec son rivet
lui il était effectivement comme ça à
temps il était peut-être un peu plus
comme ça et lui comme sa bombe à 4 4 sur
6 j'ai trouvé un peu rapide bon même pas
passé compliqué bizarrement pour moi
celui ci était plus dur que celui là on
passe au suivant
on passe maintenant dans la cour des
grands 5 sur 6 le cast skweres bon comme
comme j'ai pas trop galérer limite plus
celui ci que sur les autres je commence
ce n'est pas dit que j'aimais mais je
commence à apprécier ce genre de casse
tête ok je comprends qu'on puisse avoir
envie de faire la collection est d'en
faire un petit peu de temps en temps
c'est quand même moins relooking boîte à
transporter ou quoi et tu peux
facilement le faire faire à quelqu'un
d'autre que toi position de départ
position de faim alors là ce qu'on peut
voir c'est qu'il ya bien quatre parties
ça on est d'accord et que la cancan
force un peu ça s'ouvre comme ça de
l'autre côté c'est pareil je fais des
pressions avant arrière pour voir ce que
ça pourrait donner
salaire s'ouvrirait comme ça
par contre c'est très joli
le défunt moitié c'est très joli mais ce
serait très très joli aussi que je
puisse le leurs maîtres comme il était
au départ
ah oui d'accord faut faire tout en
symétrie donc quand le tir ça s'étire
après ça bloque si je le fais sans tout
tenir en même temps genre juste les deux
duos
j'ai pas vu qui allait avec qui commence
est tombé à t'en dirai une armure
démonter des chevaliers du zodiaque ça
se fasse assez les chaussures de pegas
c'est sûr ok pas très dur à défaire à
refaire là il va me falloir le dessin au
début on avait ça en dessous on avait sa
part déjà est ce qu est ce que je sais
en boîte et deux ensemble oui
ça allait comme ça
ok et après là dedans dans tout ça
annoncé qu'il est tombé dans le mauvais
sens la veille avait de lui
comme ça il ya des picots et tout ça va
être la mort des quoi qu'ils
bloqueraient là pourquoi ça n'irait pas
assez parce que lui lie force trop ici
et oui merci on a tous défend même temps
on ne peut pas tout remettre en même
temps fabien celui donc voilà la merde
mais là je le défie n'arrive plus à les
enlever ah oui mais lui il avait un
picot et c'est pour ça que j'ai pas plus
ça m'arrangerait ok j'ai tout re dfl
[Musique]
je me demande si si je le fais comme ça
est-ce que j'ai pas moyen d'y arriver
plus facile genre je rentre les deux en
même temps
dans leur truc
non pas tant il faut que les couleurs et
le switch la découverte est à switcher
avec mon histoire
elle suit forcément puisque est
tellement
je pense qu'il faut essayer de touré a
ressemblé en même temps puisque j'ai
tout des assemblées en même temps il est
dit que j'essaie de
faire coïncider tout ça
mais cas de l'espoir aux
eaux le veuf ben c'est bon c'est plié
c'est plié mais alors c'est aux poils de
cheveux qui sont pas sur la tête c'est
un casse-tête rondement mené l'une quand
même un pour un 5 sur 6 alors attention
et je me laraque pas en mode je les fais
vite parce que je fais quand même
énormément de castets comme vous avez vu
ces quatre dernières années donc j'ai
aussi des réflexes et sûrement un peu de
patience mais mais vite vite vite vite
cassé le tram il y en a un autre quand
même qu'on n'a pas fait c'est le cast
infiniti castard si infinity ans que je
fais et il faudra que tu vas lui signer
au montage le moment où je leur ai
assemble celui ci on se garde pour une
prochaine fois dans ce cas et comme
c'est un 6 sur 6 je pense quand même que
j'en aurai pour une vie elle faire donc
ça va ça vaut peut-être une vidéo
entière dites moi dans les commentaires
si anaya massa vous plaît comme style de
casse tête moi je suis chaud pour
construire face comme ça une série genre
beaucoup de facile d'un coup un peu le
médium mois ou très peu d'intermédiaires
ou un ou deux dur ou un extrêmement dur
on peut se faire comme ça des séries
très attention si vous en voulez des
comme ça deux solutions soit vous allez
sur mon instagram et je vais vous les
faire gagner sur le post qui paraîtra
aujourd'hui vous le repérer facilement
parce que il caster seront photos sur le
post ça c'est la solution la plus simple
et la moins onéreuse si vous voulez vous
en acheter je vous mets le site de
l'insoluble dans la description comme ça
vous pouvez en choper chez lui vous avez
aussi dans la description je voulais
dire mon spectacle qui reprend sa
tournée a la base je suis sur scène je
fais des spectacles d'humour et de
mentalisme on se retrouve dans quelques
jours pour la vidéo c'est quoi la
prochaine vidéo le hic c'est que cabinet
quorus catherine me sens mieux c'est
lundi prochain avec aq ce lot et moi je
vous mets deux autres vidéos ici c'est
les deux dernières vidéos parodiant nice
et sur les super pouvoirs des
super-héros versus et la société et
l'autre c'est le matière grise numéro 10
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
c'est à moi